bonjour jean lassalle merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous second candidat à la
présidentielle nous recevons ce matin
vous êtes candidat pour votre mouvement
résiste on est toujours à mes côtés pour
vous interroger stéphane bern et de
ouest france qui va vous poser la
première question je suis la salle
bonjour la guerre se poursuit en ukraine
vladimir poutine est toujours aussi
déterminé si vous étiez président la
république que feriez vous est ce que
est ce que vous agiriez comme aimait le
maquereau ou pas j'ai déjà eu l'occasion
de répéter à plusieurs reprises que
c'était une tragédie une attitude la
dernière poutine était
étable à ça qu il ne pourrait pas
trouver la moindre explication
rationnelle nîmes bat
maintenant j'en passe comme la question
où sont nos services de renseignement à
part les américains nous sommes informés
depuis trois mois
qu'est-ce qu'on allait en france et
qu'est-ce qu'on a ri à propos de
l'australie car nous avons tout perdu
car que nous at on dit au mali lorsque
nous avons été virés est ce qu'il y à
oui ou non encore dans ce pays * quand
espionnage et la dgse se trouve que
j'étais à la commission de la défense
nationale mais juliane charton rencontré
plusieurs hauts dignitaires infuse deux
responsables la dgse ils sont écoeurés
parce qu'ils n'ont plus l'ordre de
travailler comme il travaillait
autrefois c'est à dire vraiment de
travailler sur les gros dossiers mais si
on avait eu des renseignements en temps
réel
on avait pris l'habitude prévenir pas
c'est que maintenant président macron
qui a des liens avec tous les jours mais
avec le niveau de relation qu'il tienne
vous avez eu quelques échanges qu'ils en
sors de ta bulle ton pays va être
écrasés toi aussi et c
est bien sûr qu'on va pouvoir l'arrêter
ça tu commentes à une période de crises
absolue très dangereuse parce qu'elle
peut vraiment
dérapé très dangereusement mais c'est
pas comme troussé à temps plein vous
pourrez dire moi je peux dire que si je
suis président
je vais essayer d'engager immédiatement
un de la relation subtile monsieur
poutine des tests monsieur battre en
saynètes on avait déjà un problème
personnel déjà il n'y a pas que lui
qu'il déteste et passez y en a d'autres
aussi mais ma crainte souvenez vous la
coupe du monde de football contre la
croatie il se met à pleuvoir déverse
poutine fait venir trois pales parapluie
un pour le président de la fédération
internationale de football comme pour la
présidente à la croatie elle pour lui il
a ce maquereau en dix minutes sur des
détails depuis donc dans votre programme
vous évoquiez un désengagement
progressif de l'otan est ce que vous
êtes toujours favorable à cette idée ce
que c'est toujours d'actualité oui parce
que le tabac serait rien qu'est-ce qu'on
vous sert à rien ça avec la turquie
c'est à dire que là avec ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui on vous désengager rien la
france de l'otan est-ce que vous
dire quoi progressif accès à quelle
échéance pour vous le plus tôt possible
moi j'y réfléchis dans des
spas ya pas de coup de baguette magique
mais il faut surtout et d'ailleurs le
faisait à sarkozy l'a dit lui-même les
structures que nous avons mises en place
ne sont plus opérantes ne sommes plus
efficaces aujourd'hui l'iphone créé mais
comment voulez-vous faire je ne cite que
la turquie et je ne cite pas d'autres
puissances mais si vous avez une au
niveau de confiance que nous avons et la
turquie ou pensais honnêtement qu'on
veut faire cette chose avec eux au vent
c'est vous dire ne voit pas le maillon
faible et en plus inquiète autant qu'ils
asticote en permanence on va parler des
conséquences en france pour les français
notamment pour les agriculteurs stéphane
et oui qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que vous
proposez pour aider les agriculteurs
dans ses tendances étant complexe
essayez de faire tourner la planche à
billets tant qu'elle pourra tourner
parce que malheureusement ça ne nous
était jamais arrivé vous important 60 %
de matières végétales dont quelques quoi
qu'il en coûte pour les agriculteurs ah
oui c'est un jour 1c alimentation
animale aujourd'hui beaucoup trop cher
de l'animal donc il faut dans un premier
temps et s'ils se disent qu'il est parce
que il y a sami 251 il n'explique pas
une ferme envers le traite c'est le
dernier mais combien y at-il de
repreneur les enfants qui regardent nous
allons faire avec sa fille mais elle
était installée maintenant elle se
demande vu leurs revenus et elle a passé
une année à travailler nuit et jour elle
n'a rien gagné que des contrôles donc je
pense qu'il faut faire fonctionner un
petit peu long voilà après donc les
conséquences de la guerre en ukraine
pour vous il faudrait il
existait déjà moi je pense dans un
premier temps il faut instaurer salaire
pour celui qui te sous
si vous avez par exemple le couple qui
sur la propriété
le résultat ne peut pas vivre de son
seul revenu le jour il va pourra rire
c'est plus utile mais comme on l'a fait
avec le conseil national de résistance
un deuxième revenu qui permettrait déjà
de restructurer un petit peu la famille
mais moi j'ai campagne de france vient
de causer nationale à laquelle je veux
contribuer 3 milliards d'euros par an
pendant mon quinquennat pour
reconstruire l'ensemble d'un tissu
territoriale et redonner
ses trois bienfaits pour la ruralité
absolument mais ça rentre dedans sinon
bien entendu il faut essayer d'avoir un
pass
un résultat ligue ne savait qui vous
permet comme c'est le cas dans quand
vous rentrez dans une faculté watts pour
payer une petite taxe intérieure et vous
avez accès à tous les services et là
c'est le producteur et l'état qu'il
paierait chacun une partie et vous
pourriez vendre vos produits un peu plus
cher et encourager les circuits de
proximité
ça ça peut marcher vous proposer
beaucoup de choses intéressantes dans
votre votre programme original mais
comme ces trois milliards d'euros par an
pour les campagnes la baisse de tva ce
dtv de la tva sur les sur les carburants
sur des embauches et des fonds pour la
recherche
mais à aucun moment vous ne vous deux
chiffres et où vous dites comment vous
allez financer l'ensemble de ces mesures
si vous étiez président la république
c'est à dire que j'ai dit au préalable
que je reconstruise est un état qui sera
de nouveau
symbole c'est la france en a besoin y a
plus d'état aujourd'hui et qui sera
facilitateur pour vite relancer la
recherche fondamentale et appliquée vite
le plus vite possible et la france a su
le faire dans le passé pour une nouvelle
forme d'énergie nous avons quand même
11 millions de kilomètres carrés qui
grâce à nos deals sur lesquels nous
pourrons tester le vrai l'énergie
solaire et l'énergie des marées et nous
ne faisons rien rien donc ça c'est à
plus long terme mais il faut le
commencer dès maintenant chacun dans un
premier temps nous sommes dans une
situation inextricable
mais le sera pour quelques présidents de
ce soir vous avez vu si monsieur macron
comme tout semble l'indiquer succède à
lui-même en choeur que je trouve que
monsieur vaqueront un acteur esaïe
interne il ad'autant lui vous le verrez
dames sont inquiets moi j'essaie d'aller
le voir hier soir à poissy je suis resté
trois heures j'ai vu passer d'ailleurs
des déciles de journalistes qui aurait
une niche parce que j'aurais été un
chien je me suis jamais plus attiré
l'attention
mais le père de quoi mais il a peur
d'abord il a toujours eu peur des gens
savent et il n'est pas à l'aise il y
faut des salles bien paraître comme les
maires et commencer à poissy
m'a fait regarder des images de prix
c'était des petites questions bien
gentillette c'est pas du tout des
questions à la mélenchon vous voyez ce
que je veux dire mais il a peur de lui
et ça ça ne guérit pas nos mois il a un
problème de calage entre ce niveau
d'intervention internationaux et la
réalité d'une campagne or comment les
français n'ont qu'un homme a perdu toute
notion politique et ils vont bien
vouloir avoir un minimum le sentiment
sur le président ils ont réélu moi je
vous dis cette affaire n'est pas
terminée parce que c'est macron lui-même
qui est le plus dangereux adversaire
pour martron
mais ça veut dire que l'élection de la
cra n'est pas du tout acquise parce que
moi je sais pas comment il va tenir
cette campagne pendant quinze jours ça
va les changer d'avis il ya quelques
semaines vous disiez que toute façon ces
macro qui gagnerait la fin non mais
parce qu'on a écourté ma footing boutade
ou non non c'est pas une totale c'était
vos fleurs phase deux qui m'ont dit
qu'elles servent aux premières mesures
j'y vis après de premières mesures
puisque c'est makoun qui veut gagner
afin de regagner compte tenu de la toute
la finance qui l'a au derrière il a tout
la finance quand vous voulez vous faire
si je n'arrive pas si nous n'arrivons
pas à faire comprendre cela par les
français et aucune chance et l'autre au
teil à vau l'eau mais qui nous a fait le
cadeau de zemmour voiliers avaient
justement j'avais une question sur eric
zemmour puisque vous êtes le candidat de
la ruralité l'hexagone propose une
pression à l'été ne me
il faut que je fasse attention à ce
qu'on ne réalise pas parce que sinon
jean lassalle il va terminer comme vous
savez on a chéri on a repris 6 des
enfants résine questions sur les amours
qui propose une prime de 10 mille euros
par naissance dans une zone rurale est
ce que ça c'est une bonne mesure pour
vos véhicules
on ne fait pas des enfants comme ça
c'est senna bien connaître la campagne
est déjà de la grande difficulté de s'y
installer
dernière question sur l'abstention c'est
qu'on voit bien que ça peut être un
point clé pour pour le résultat le
résultat final comment est-ce que
comment est ce qu'on pourrait inciter
les électeurs et les électrices de ce
pays à aller voter massivement
actuellement il ya la can dont cinq ont
voté et si ça reste comme ça mc ren est
réélu car ces
barrettes autorisé le tout et vous avez
raison c'est de faire voter 10 ou 20
personnes de plus moi je pars avec un
bus de la maternologie chien il faut le
faire il valoir il faut quand même avoir
un peu de courage un bus le pour faire
un tour de france et j'ai prévenu
personne n'y aurait pas beaucoup de
monde mais tous les médias vont venir et
il y assure et ibos se payer ma poire
attendre qu'il peut mais comment
voulez-vous aller parler à des gilet
jaune complètement oublié à des hommes
frustrés et les femmes frustrées par le
passé ni terre qui ne croient plus en
rien et qui ne vont pas voter moi je
fais c'est interdit et oui parce que je
m'arrête et puis on essaie d'ouvrir le
débat y'a pas moyen de l'ouvrir merci
jean lassalle merci au bain-marie merci
je suis sensible à votre invitation mais
c'est bien normal on donne la parole à
tous les candidats merci beaucoup
d'avoir été notre invité
[Musique]